Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get on to the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end.
Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get on to the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end.|||嗨，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家合集》这本书来帮助自己准备第一轮博士申请，我很高兴我这么做了。看到其他人如何反思他们的心路历程非常有启发性，这让我对自己的历程和技能有很多反思。这也帮助我以正确的视角看待事物，并提醒我，如果今年我没有考上博士，那也没关系。然而，这本书最意想不到的乐趣，莫过于每个人的旅程都是多么鼓舞人心。每天把这些故事作为我早上的动力真是一大乐事。我几乎舍不得读到结局。
The let them movement is everywhere right now. And for a lot of people, it feels empowering. But in clinical work, we're starting to see something else happen. I've heard clients quote it in therapy and I've seen what happens when they start to use it as protection rather than reflection. So today I'm sitting down with a fellow psychologist Dr. Rana to ask the uncomfortable question, has let them gone too far? Because what if this isn't empowerment? What if this is avoidance dressed up as confidence?
The let them movement is everywhere right now. And for a lot of people, it feels empowering. But in clinical work, we're starting to see something else happen. I've heard clients quote it in therapy and I've seen what happens when they start to use it as protection rather than reflection. So today I'm sitting down with a fellow psychologist Dr. Rana to ask the uncomfortable question, has let them gone too far? Because what if this isn't empowerment? What if this is avoidance dressed up as confidence?|||“随他去吧”（let them）这股潮流现在到处都是。对很多人来说，这感觉赋予了他们力量。但在临床工作中，我们开始看到另一种情况发生。我听过来访者在治疗中引用这句话，我也见过当他们开始用它作为保护而非反思时会发生什么。所以今天我与同行心理学家拉娜博士坐在一起，提出了一个让人不太舒服的问题：“随他去吧”是不是走得太远了？因为如果这根本不是赋权呢？如果这只是伪装成自信的逃避呢？
let them actually helping people heal or is it helping them to disconnect from others faster? I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. I hope you find this content so helpful. And if you do, like and subscribe for more. Welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. I am joined here today by a Canadian clinical psychologist, Dr. Rana. Hi, welcome along Rana. Hi, thank you so much for having me. I'm excited to be here. Absolutely. So we thought it'd be really interesting to have a chat about kind of inspired by a global phenomenon of a book called Let Them by Mel Robbins. And in a very small nutshell,
let them actually helping people heal or is it helping them to disconnect from others faster? I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. I hope you find this content so helpful. And if you do, like and subscribe for more. Welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. I am joined here today by a Canadian clinical psychologist, Dr. Rana. Hi, welcome along Rana. Hi, thank you so much for having me. I'm excited to be here. Absolutely. So we thought it'd be really interesting to have a chat about kind of inspired by a global phenomenon of a book called Let Them by Mel Robbins. And in a very small nutshell,|||“随他去吧”真的在帮助人们疗愈吗？还是在帮助他们更快地与他人切断联系？我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。希望你觉得这些内容很有帮助。如果是的话，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。欢迎收听有志心理学家播客。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天和我在一起的是加拿大临床心理学家拉娜博士。嗨，欢迎你，拉娜。嗨，非常感谢邀请我来。我很兴奋能来到这里。完全同意。所以我们觉得聊一聊这个话题会非常有趣，灵感来自于梅·罗宾斯（Mel Robbins）的一本名为《随他去吧》的全球现象级畅销书。简而言之，
an example of that would be if someone's really upset with me for something that they think I've done, you know, maybe I can let them, but I can choose to, you know, go and make a new friend, or I can choose to talk to them about it, or I can choose to make sure that in future I don't let that happen in relationships. So it's putting the onus on me and just kind of saying, people will be people and I'm maybe not the centre of their world. That's kind of what I took from it. But you kind of, and I were discussing whether actually maybe let them has gone a little bit too far. And I would love. I would love your take on that runner.
an example of that would be if someone's really upset with me for something that they think I've done, you know, maybe I can let them, but I can choose to, you know, go and make a new friend, or I can choose to talk to them about it, or I can choose to make sure that in future I don't let that happen in relationships. So it's putting the onus on me and just kind of saying, people will be people and I'm maybe not the centre of their world. That's kind of what I took from it. But you kind of, and I were discussing whether actually maybe let them has gone a little bit too far. And I would love. I would love your take on that runner.|||举个例子，如果有人因为他们认为我做过的事而对我非常生气，你知道，也许我可以随他去吧，但我可以选择去结交新朋友，或者我可以选择和他们谈谈这件事，或者我可以选择确保在未来的关系中不再让这种事发生。所以这是把责任放在我身上，只是在某种程度上说，人就是人，我可能不是他们世界的中心。这就是我从中领悟到的。但你和我一直在讨论，实际上“随他去吧”可能有点走得太远了。我很想听听你的看法，拉娜。
Absolutely. I started noticing that the pendulum might have been swinging too far when I was seeing versions of either quotes from the book or bits of the interviews or even clients coming in telling me that they had read this book or other books like it where there is a very self-focused path to wellness. And I'll start off by saying that the message in Let Them or Similar Books are really, come from a positive place.
Absolutely. I started noticing that the pendulum might have been swinging too far when I was seeing versions of either quotes from the book or bits of the interviews or even clients coming in telling me that they had read this book or other books like it where there is a very self-focused path to wellness. And I'll start off by saying that the message in Let Them or Similar Books are really, come from a positive place.|||完全同意。当我看到书中引言的版本、采访片段，甚至来访者走进诊室告诉我他们读过这本书或类似书籍时，我开始注意到天平可能已经倾斜得太远了，这些书提供了一条高度关注自我的健康之路。首先我要说的是，《随他去吧》或类似书籍中的信息确实源于一个积极的角度。
They're really clever repackaging of things that we have already known about. Things like personal responsibility, focusing on what you can control, accepting people for who they are instead of trying to change them over and over again. But what I was noticing was happening is that folks were overcorrecting and in the way that they were applying it. Because there was such a desire to change the way that they were relating to others. And so they were putting into, in short, we're putting into place these strategies of, oh, let them. That's not, you know, not my circus, not my monkeys. I'm not going to deal with that.
They're really clever repackaging of things that we have already known about. Things like personal responsibility, focusing on what you can control, accepting people for who they are instead of trying to change them over and over again. But what I was noticing was happening is that folks were overcorrecting and in the way that they were applying it. Because there was such a desire to change the way that they were relating to others. And so they were putting into, in short, we're putting into place these strategies of, oh, let them. That's not, you know, not my circus, not my monkeys. I'm not going to deal with that.|||它们是对我们已经知道的事情的非常巧妙的重新包装。比如个人责任、专注于你能控制的事情、接受人们本来的样子而不是试图一次又但我注意到发生的情况是，人们在应用这些方法时进行了过度矫正。因为他们非常渴望改变自己与他人建立关系的方式。因此，简而言之，他们正在实施这些策略：“哦，随他去吧。那不是，你知道的，不是我的马戏团，不是我的猴子。我才不管那事呢。”
Yet people continued to feel lonely, frustrated, and resentful. And what I was realizing is that we're putting these strategies in place before doing the work and then expecting other people to change. So I thought it was interesting to bring this to the surface and discuss it not just in terms of this book, but also as a general trend of these self-focused wellness. trends. Absolutely. And so in case people aren't really getting what we mean or they're wondering if they're interpreting the book properly or in a less helpful way, without identifying any particular client. And maybe I can give you a moment to think. Could you think of a case study
Yet people continued to feel lonely, frustrated, and resentful. And what I was realizing is that we're putting these strategies in place before doing the work and then expecting other people to change. So I thought it was interesting to bring this to the surface and discuss it not just in terms of this book, but also as a general trend of these self-focused wellness. trends. Absolutely. And so in case people aren't really getting what we mean or they're wondering if they're interpreting the book properly or in a less helpful way, without identifying any particular client. And maybe I can give you a moment to think. Could you think of a case study|||然而，人们依然感到孤独、沮丧和怨恨。我所意识到的是，我们在没有做好内心工作之前就实施了这些策略，然后期望其他人改变。所以我认为把这一点浮出水面并加以讨论很有意思，不仅是从这本书的角度，而且是作为这些以自我为中心的健康趋势的普遍趋势。完全同意。因此，以防人们没有真正理解我们的意思，或者他们在想自己是否正确理解了这本书，或者是否以一种不太有帮助的方式理解，在不指明任何特定来访者的前提下。也许我可以给你一点时间思考。你能想出一个案例研究吗？
where someone's maybe not quite getting it right in a way that's actually helping their relationships to be functional? Absolutely. So there are a lot of examples, but some of them are actually tend to happen around different holidays, so whether it's sort of Christmas that just passed or even summer holidays or whatnot, because these are the times where people's time, they need to often share their time. Either it's for family or friends,
where someone's maybe not quite getting it right in a way that's actually helping their relationships to be functional? Absolutely. So there are a lot of examples, but some of them are actually tend to happen around different holidays, so whether it's sort of Christmas that just passed or even summer holidays or whatnot, because these are the times where people's time, they need to often share their time. Either it's for family or friends,|||在这个案例中，有人可能没有完全弄对方法，而这种方法实际上正在帮助他们的人际关系正常运转？当然可以。有很多例子，但其中一些实际上往往发生在不同的节日期间，无论是刚刚过去的圣诞节，还是暑假之类的时候，因为这些时候人们的时间需要经常分担。无论是给家人还是朋友，
there's lots of demands or pressure on their time. And so what I was noticing is folks wanting to, for instance, a client wanting to set boundaries around how they were going to spend a long weekend. And historically, this was a weekend, It was Canada, I can't remember, where it was a family event. But this wasn't something that they wanted to do that year. They had a new partner and they wanted to spend that with them.
there's lots of demands or pressure on their time. And so what I was noticing is folks wanting to, for instance, a client wanting to set boundaries around how they were going to spend a long weekend. And historically, this was a weekend, It was Canada, I can't remember, where it was a family event. But this wasn't something that they wanted to do that year. They had a new partner and they wanted to spend that with them.|||人们的时间面临着很多需求或压力。因此我注意到的是，人们想要——例如，一个来访者想要围绕他们将如何度过一个小长假设定界限。从历史上看，这是一个周末，那是加拿大，我记不清了，这是一个家庭活动。但这不是他们那一年想做的事情。他们有了一个新伴侣，他们想和伴侣一起度过。
And the way that it was brought in and the way that they talked to me about having set this boundary was, I texted my mom, I told her I'm not going to the cottage that I wanted to see my boyfriend that weekend. And they were so upset that their mother was expressing disappointment and kind of even trying to convince her otherwise. And her reaction was to sort of not respond to her mom for a week. And to me, knowing what I knew about this client, it felt like a really strong reaction where she was hoping for something from mom. Mom didn't give it to me. Oh, let them, I'm walking away from this. That's not working. Now, of course, there's a lot to unpack in this particular relationship, hence why she was in therapy. But these type of knee-jerk, strong reactions that we're calling
And the way that it was brought in and the way that they talked to me about having set this boundary was, I texted my mom, I told her I'm not going to the cottage that I wanted to see my boyfriend that weekend. And they were so upset that their mother was expressing disappointment and kind of even trying to convince her otherwise. And her reaction was to sort of not respond to her mom for a week. And to me, knowing what I knew about this client, it felt like a really strong reaction where she was hoping for something from mom. Mom didn't give it to me. Oh, let them, I'm walking away from this. That's not working. Now, of course, there's a lot to unpack in this particular relationship, hence why she was in therapy. But these type of knee-jerk, strong reactions that we're calling|||引入这件事的方式以及他们跟我谈论他们如何设定这个界限的方式是：“我给我妈发了短信，告诉她我不会去乡间别墅了，我周末想去看男朋友。”他们对母亲表达失望甚至试图说服她改变主意感到非常沮丧。她的反应是有一周时间不回复她妈妈。对我来说，结合我对这位来访者的了解，这感觉像是一种非常激烈的反应，她当时希望从妈妈那里得到某些东西。“妈妈没有给我。哦，随他去吧，我不管了，走开。”这行不通。当然，这段特定的关系中有很多东西需要剖析，这也是她接受治疗的原因。但我们称之为这种膝跳反射式的、强烈的反应，
boundaries were actually harmful because she was left still frustrated, still did. disappointed in mom, even though she was letting mom have her reaction. That's one example that I can think of is very much shows up around time demands. Yeah. And also, I guess that would be suggesting that you operate in a silo and we don't. So actually, if your relationship with your mom is still important, then I guess I'd be encouraging any client to say, I'm really sorry. I know that often we do usually get together, but this time I'd like to do something a little bit different and, you know, I am feeling really tired and I don't want to make the drive. And, you know, I've got this new relationship and I would really like to just spend it with them. I know you might
boundaries were actually harmful because she was left still frustrated, still did. disappointed in mom, even though she was letting mom have her reaction. That's one example that I can think of is very much shows up around time demands. Yeah. And also, I guess that would be suggesting that you operate in a silo and we don't. So actually, if your relationship with your mom is still important, then I guess I'd be encouraging any client to say, I'm really sorry. I know that often we do usually get together, but this time I'd like to do something a little bit different and, you know, I am feeling really tired and I don't want to make the drive. And, you've got this new relationship and I would really like to just spend it with them. I know you might|||界限，实际上是有害的，因为她依然感到沮丧，依然对妈妈感到失望，尽管她正在允许妈妈做出自己的反应。这是我能想到的一个例子，它非常多地出现在时间需求周围。是的。而且，我想这也暗示了你是在一个孤岛中运作，而我们不是。所以实际上，如果你和你妈妈的关系依然重要，那么我想我会鼓励任何来访者说：“非常抱歉。我知道通常我们确实会聚在一起，但这次我想做点稍微不同的事情，而且，你知道的，我真的觉得很累，不想开车去。而且，你有了这段新关系，我真的很想只和他们在一起度过。我知道你可能会
be disappointed about that. And, you know, I'm a bit disappointed as well because I do enjoy that time together. But maybe we could find a different time to spend together or if this works out, I could bring them next time. It's not just saying, I'm doing this. It's almost like blubbing a hand grenade, isn't it? I'm doing this. I don't care what you say. And I'm not going to respond to you. That's almost like, was it passive aggressive? Is that the right term? Like it's, I don't know if that's passive, but it's, you know, I like the hand grenade idea or this idea of walking away from like a burning car, right? I was like, ah, it's not mine to deal with. Those are your feelings. You deal with them. And what ascribing to these models rigidly does is that it really stifles our curiosity about other people.
be disappointed about that. And, you know, I'm a bit disappointed as well because I do enjoy that time together. But maybe we could find a different time to spend together or if this works out, I could bring them next time. It's not just saying, I'm doing this. It's almost like blubbing a hand grenade, isn't it? I'm doing this. I don't care what you say. And I'm not going to respond to you. That's almost like, was it passive aggressive? Is that the right term? Like it's, I don't know if that's passive, but it's, you know, I like the hand grenade idea or this idea of walking away from like a burning car, right? I was like, ah, it's not mine to deal with. Those are your feelings. You deal with them. And what ascribing to these models rigidly does is that it really stifles our curiosity about other people.|||对此感到失望。而且，你知道的，我也觉得有点失望，因为我很享受我们在一起的时光。但也许我们可以找另一个时间聚聚，或者如果这次行得通，我下次可以带他一起来。”这不仅仅是说：“我就要这么做。”这几乎就像扔一颗手榴弹，对吧？“我就要这么做。我不在乎你怎么说。我不会回复你。”这几乎就像是，是消极攻击吗？这是正确的术语吗？就像是，我不知道这算不算消极，但你知道的，我喜欢手榴弹的想法，或者这种像从一辆着火的汽车旁走开的想法，对吧？我就像是：“啊，这不归我管。那是你的感受。你自己处理吧。”而僵化地信奉这些模式所做的事情，是它真正扼杀了我们对其他人的好奇心。
And, you know, why would my mom be upset if I canceled? Or another sort of like pattern that's noticeable, even if I'm talking to folks in general, is around canceling last minute plans because we had made these plans for brunch, but I'm canceling because I'm feeling really tired. And it's sort of like, well, you made a commitment to three other people who are waiting for you at the restaurant, right? But, oh, but I'm taking care of me. Like, let them be upset. But it stifles our curiosity about, like, how come this other person is upset?
And, you know, why would my mom be upset if I canceled? Or another sort of like pattern that's noticeable, even if I'm talking to folks in general, is around canceling last minute plans because we had made these plans for brunch, but I'm canceling because I'm feeling really tired. And it's sort of like, well, you made a commitment to three other people who are waiting for you at the restaurant, right? But, oh, but I'm taking care of me. Like, let them be upset. But it stifles our curiosity about, like, how come this other person is upset?|||你知道的，如果我取消了计划，我妈妈为什么会生气呢？或者另一种值得注意的模式，即使我在和一般人交谈时也是如此，那就是在最后一分钟取消计划，因为我们原本约好了吃早午餐，但我取消了，因为我感觉真的很累。这就有点像是，好吧，你对其他三个在餐厅等你的其他人做出了承诺，对吧？但是，“哦，但我正在照顾我自己。随他们生气去吧。”但这扼杀了我们的好奇心，比如，为什么另一个人会生气？
How come this other person is acting the way that they are? And curiosity is, I think, the start of any change. And when we're not curious about why we're setting a boundary or when, or we're not curious about why someone else is responding the way that they are, then we're disconnecting, right? Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. And I don't know, I think one of our strengths as psychologists is to be curious about others. Right? Incessantly curious.
How come this other person is acting the way that they are? And curiosity is, I think, the start of any change. And when we're not curious about why we're setting a boundary or when, or we're not curious about why someone else is responding the way that they are, then we're disconnecting, right? Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. And I don't know, I think one of our strengths as psychologists is to be curious about others. Right? Incessantly curious.|||为什么另一个人会有这样的举动？我认为好奇心是任何改变的开始。当我们不好奇我们为什么要设定界限或何时设定界限时，或者当我们不好奇为什么别人会有这样的反应时，我们就在切断联系，对吗？是的。是的，完全同意。而且我不知道，我认为作为心理学家，我们的优势之一就是对他人保持好奇。对吧？永无止境的好奇。
I'm relentlessly curious. I love knowing about people and about people's wives. And it's one of the things I found challenging in the pandemic because everyone was wearing masks and then you didn't get to speak to people, to strangers. If I may, you know, the additional layer that I'm seeing now, and again, this is in my office, but also in sort of like broader communication
I'm relentlessly curious. I love knowing about people and about people's wives. And it's one of the things I found challenging in the pandemic because everyone was wearing masks and then you didn't get to speak to people, to strangers. If I may, you know, the additional layer that I'm seeing now, and again, this is in my office, but also in sort of like broader communication|||我有着不依不饶的好奇心。我喜欢了解人们以及人们的生活。这是我在疫情期间觉得具有挑战性的事情之一，因为每个人都戴着口罩，然后你就无法与人、与陌生人交谈。如果可以的话，你知道的，我现在看到的另一个层面——同样，这既发生在我的办公室里，也发生在更广泛的交流中——
or discussions around mental health is folks turning to AI therapy for support, whether it's therapy or just the regular chat bot that they happen to be using for emotional support, what did those bots do is that they reinforce, they're so agreeable that they reinforce your point of view. So if you say, should I cancel these plans with my friends, I'm feeling really tired, they'll say, oh, yes, you're taking care of yourself, you go ahead and do that. And let them will tell you, yeah, let them be upset, you know. Because you are taking control of what you can. The second half of the book, the let me,
or discussions around mental health is folks turning to AI therapy for support, whether it's therapy or just the regular chat bot that they happen to be using for emotional support, what did those bots do is that they reinforce, they're so agreeable that they reinforce your point of view. So if you say, should I cancel these plans with my friends, I'm feeling really tired, they'll say, oh, yes, you're taking care of yourself, you go ahead and do that. And let them will tell you, yeah, let them be upset, you know. Because you are taking control of what you can. The second half of the book, the let me,|||或者围绕心理健康的讨论中，人们开始转向人工智能治疗来寻求支持，无论是治疗还是他们碰巧用来获取情感支持的常规聊天机器人，这些机器人所做的是它们会强化，它们太随和了，以至于会强化你的观点。所以如果你说：“我应该取消和朋友们的这些计划吗？我感觉真的很累。”它们会说：“哦，是的，你在照顾自己，你尽管去这样做吧。”“随他去吧”会告诉你：“对，随他们生气去吧，你知道的。因为你在掌控你能掌控的事情。”这本书的后半部分，“随我来”（let me），
it's like, you're taking control where you can. But that is very, very narrow-minded. And these chatbots will reinforce that and isolate us. You've given me an idea then for when kind of automation and AI kind of gets it a little bit wrong. So I'm going to ask you to pay me a compliment. So I'm feeling a little bit wobbly, maybe not feeling great about myself. you say something nice about me, please? Absolutely. I was thinking actually that I really like your necklace. It's very colourful and we don't wear long necklaces anymore and I kind of miss that.
it's like, you're taking control where you can. But that is very, very narrow-minded. And these chatbots will reinforce that and isolate us. You've given me an idea then for when kind of automation and AI kind of gets it a little bit wrong. So I'm going to ask you to pay me a compliment. So I'm feeling a little bit wobbly, maybe not feeling great about myself. you say something nice about me, please? Absolutely. I was thinking actually that I really like your necklace. It's very colourful and we don't wear long necklaces anymore and I kind of miss that.|||就好像是，你在力所能及的地方进行掌控。但这是非常非常狭隘的。这些聊天机器人会强化这一点并孤立我们。那么你给了我一个灵感，关于自动化和人工智能在什么时候会有点搞错。所以我要请你夸夸我。所以我现在感觉有点动摇，可能对自己的感觉不太好。你能夸夸我吗？当然可以。其实我在想，我真的很喜欢你的项链。它颜色非常鲜艳，我们现在都不戴长项链了，我有点想念这种风格。
Okay. Thank you. So I was watching a creator yesterday called Mama Still Got It, doing quite a raw reel about not feeling herself, feeling like, you know, maybe she wasn't feeling her most attractive that day, feeling like she wasn't being the best mother that she wanted to be. And, you know, hair wasn't haering and, you know, skin wasn't skinning, even the light in the room wasn't quite right. And as part of that, she'd said, oh, you know, Alexa, pay me a compliment. And it was something along the lines of your, in terms of awesomeness, your unicorn riding on a dragon. And I was just a bit like, it's just too much, you know, it's just, that doesn't really, that doesn't really do much for me. You know, for me it would be much better to say, for them to say, actually, you know,
Okay. Thank you. So I was watching a creator yesterday called Mama Still Got It, doing quite a raw reel about not feeling herself, feeling like, you know, maybe she wasn't feeling her most attractive that day, feeling like she wasn't being the best mother that she wanted to be. And, you know, hair wasn't haering and, you know, skin wasn't skinning, even the light in the room wasn't quite right. And as part of that, she'd said, oh, you know, Alexa, pay me a compliment. And it was something along the lines of your, in terms of awesomeness, your unicorn riding on a dragon. And I was just a bit like, it's just too much, you know, it's just, that doesn't really, that doesn't really do much for me. You know, for me it would be much better to say, for them to say, actually, you know,|||好的。谢谢你。所以昨天我看到一个名为“妈妈风韵犹存”（Mama Still Got It）的创作者，发了一段非常真实短视频，讲述她感觉不在状态，感觉自己那天可能不是最具吸引力的，感觉自己没有成为她想成为的最好的母亲。而且，你知道的，头发不听话，皮肤状态不好，甚至房间里的光线都不太对劲。作为其中的一部分，她曾说：“哦，你知道的，亚历山大（Alexa），夸夸我。”大意是你在惊艳程度方面，就像骑着龙的独角兽。我当时就觉得，这有点太过分了，你知道的，这根本，这对我来说没多大作用。你知道的，对我来说，如果能说——如果他们能说，实际上，你知道的，
you've got a really kind heart and you, you know, you mean to do the right things and, you know, your listeners really love what you have to say and you're doing a good job. None of us, none of us find this easy any of the time. And that for me has got more usefulness and more believability, more utility. What do you think? Absolutely. It's something that is, well, individual to you. It's based on who you are, right, as opposed to this sort of mythical creature compares. I don't even, I don't know, I feel like my daughter might really like that as a compliment, but like, I'm not sure that like it would work in an interpersonal relationship. And, What I think is really interesting is that doing that, the automatic response of going to a
you've got a really kind heart and you, you know, you mean to do the right things and, you know, your listeners really love what you have to say and you're doing a good job. None of us, none of us find this easy any of the time. And that for me has got more usefulness and more believability, more utility. What do you think? Absolutely. It's something that is, well, individual to you. It's based on who you are, right, as opposed to this sort of mythical creature compares. I don't even, I don't know, I feel like my daughter might really like that as a compliment, but like, I'm not sure that like it would work in an interpersonal relationship. And, What I think is really interesting is that doing that, the automatic response of going to a|||你有一颗非常善良的心，而且，你知道的，你的本意是做正确的事，而且，你知道的，你的听众真的很喜欢你所说的话，你做得很好。我们所有人，无论何时都不会觉得这很容易。对我而言，这更有用、更可信、更有实用价值。你觉得呢？完全同意。这是属于你个人的东西。它基于你是谁，对吧，而不是像这种神话生物的对比。我甚至，我不知道，我觉得我女儿可能会非常喜欢这样的赞美，但像，我不确定这在人际关系中是否行得通。而且，我认为非常有趣的是，这样做——向某人寻求赞美的自动反应——
machine for a compliment sort of tells me two things. The first is, how come we're not turning to each other? What if I sent my sister a text and said, feeling really crummy, send me something funny, right? Why can't I do that to a real person? and I feel that I have to go to a machine. That's sort of one thing. And then the other part is the practice that it takes away.
machine for a compliment sort of tells me two things. The first is, how come we're not turning to each other? What if I sent my sister a text and said, feeling really crummy, send me something funny, right? Why can't I do that to a real person? and I feel that I have to go to a machine. That's sort of one thing. And then the other part is the practice that it takes away.|||向机器寻求赞美，这在某种程度上告诉我两件事。第一，为什么我们不向彼此求助？如果我给我妹妹发短信说“感觉糟糕透了，给我发点搞笑的东西”，对吧？为什么我不能对一个真人这样做？而我觉得我必须去找一台机器。这算是一点。然后另一部分是它剥夺了我们的练习。
So if I'm feeling crummy, I'm not working through the different steps, drawing on myself to challenge that, knowing that, you know what, I felt like this before. Hey, I actually have a journal entry about a time. where I knew where I know reading that makes me feel good. Or I'm going to put on a song and dance. I'm going to draw on my own resources rather than again going to a machine. And so while AI, it does give a lot, can give tools and information and life.
So if I'm feeling crummy, I'm not working through the different steps, drawing on myself to challenge that, knowing that, you know what, I've felt like this before. Hey, I actually have a journal entry about a time. where I knew where I know reading that makes me feel good. Or I'm going to put on a song and dance. I'm going to draw on my own resources rather than again going to a machine. And so while AI, it does give a lot, can give tools and information and life.|||所以如果我感觉糟糕透了，我没有经历不同的步骤，依靠自己去挑战这种情绪，去意识到，你知道吗，我以前也有过这种感觉。嘿，我实际上有一篇日记记录了一段时期，我知道——我知道读那篇日记会让我感觉良好。或者我要放一首歌跳个舞。我要依靠我自己的资源，而不是再次去找机器。因此，虽然人工智能确实给予了很多，能够提供工具、信息和生活帮助，
I said I didn't use it. It prevents us from learning the skills we would want to learn to be efficient. And it disconnects us from people who could support us in a way who could foster these relationships, right? Yeah. And, yeah, so if I did go with that, I'm feeling really crummy example. And if I did say to my husband, I'm feeling really crummy, say something nice about me or to one of my friends, and they came back with your unicorn riding on a dragon, I would be, in terms of the let them stuff, I personally would feel like you don't even get me. That's not authentic.
I said I didn't use it. It prevents us from learning the skills we would want to learn to be efficient. And it disconnects us from people who could support us in a way who could foster these relationships, right? Yeah. And, yeah, so if I did go with that, I'm feeling really crummy example. And if I did say to my husband, I'm feeling really crummy, say something nice about me or to one of my friends, and they came back with your unicorn riding on a dragon, I would be, in terms of the let them stuff, I personally would feel like you don't even get me. That's not authentic.|||我说我没用它。它阻止我们学习为了提高效率而想要学习的技能。它切断了我们与那些能够以某种方式支持我们、能够培养这些关系的人的联系，对吧？是的。而且，是的，所以如果我真的用了那个“我感觉糟糕透了”的例子。如果我真的对我的丈夫说“我感觉糟糕透了，说点夸我的话吧”或者对我的一个朋友说，而他们的回答是“你就像骑着龙的独角兽”，在“随他去吧”这件事上，我个人会觉得你根本不懂我。那不是真实的。
you know, you're my best friend or you're my husband and this is the best you've got. And go down the let them thing, you know, what if we were using the let them inappropriately, we'd be saying, well, I can let them think that that's going to scratch my itch and I can scratch my own itch and say something nice about myself. And there's a whole thing about internal, external, you know, validation and kind of, you know, all of that jazz, making ourselves feel good enough. But if we just left that with them, we would have a relationship which isn't meeting my needs because actually I want something that feels like they know me
you know, my best friend or you're my husband and this is the best you've got. And go down the let them thing, you know, what if we were using the let them inappropriately, we'd be saying, well, I can let them think that that's going to scratch my itch and I can scratch my own itch and say something nice about myself. And there's a whole thing about internal, external, you know, validation and kind of, you know, all of that jazz, making ourselves feel good enough. But if we just left that with them, we would have a relationship which isn't meeting my needs because actually I want something that feels like they know me|||你知道的，你是我的最好朋友或者你是我的丈夫，而这就是你能给出的最好的东西了。顺着“随他去吧”这件事想下去，你知道的，如果我们不恰当地使用“随他去吧”，我们就会说：“好吧，我可以由着他们认为那能止痒，而我自己可以挠痒痒，对自己说点好听的话。”这里面有一整套关于内在、外在（你知道的）认可，以及诸如此类的一切，让我们觉得自己足够好。但如果我们把这一切仅仅留给他们，我们的关系就无法满足我的需求，因为实际上我想要的是那种让他们觉得他们了解我的感觉——
and they genuinely value me as a person. So that would be an example of how we'd get let them wrong. Yeah, I think so. because you would have this sense of like, well, first you'd have that disappointment, and then you have this sense of like, oh, this person isn't going to get me. This person doesn't understand me. This person doesn't meet my needs. So I'm going to let them be how they are.
and they genuinely value me as a person. So that would be an example of how we'd get let them wrong. Yeah, I think so. because you would have this sense of like, well, first you'd have that disappointment, and then you have this sense of like, oh, this person isn't going to get me. This person doesn't understand me. This person doesn't meet my needs. So I'm going to let them be how they are.|||并且他们真心把我当个人来看待。所以这将是一个我们如何把“随他去吧”用错的例子。是的，我也这么认为。因为你会有这样一种感觉：首先你会感到失望，然后你会有这样一种感觉：“哦，这个人不会理解我。这个人不了解我。这个人无法满足我的需求。所以我要随他去吧，由他去好了。”
And they let me, I'm going to stop going to them to get my needs met. And that's just going to set us apart. Now, that being said, it's possible that we're going to learn over time that this person just doesn't know how to get it. Like, they give me a solution when what I want is a hug, right? Like, and I've tried, I tried. Sure. Then the responsibility is on you to pivot and say, okay, this is not the type of support this person is going to be able to give me. But I can go to so and so.
And they let me, I'm going to stop going to them to get my needs met. And that's just going to set us apart. Now, that being said, it's possible that we're going to learn over time that this person just doesn't know how to get it. Like, they give me a solution when what I want is a hug, right? Like, and I've tried, I tried. Sure. Then the responsibility is on you to pivot and say, okay, this is not the type of support this person is going to be able to give me. But I can go to so and so.|||他们随我去了，我也将停止去找他们来满足我的需求。而这只会让我们疏远。话虽如此，随着时间的推移，我们可能会了解到这个人就是不知道该怎么做。比如，当我想要一个拥抱时，他们却给我一个解决方案，对吧？比如，我试过了，我试过了。当然。那责任就在于你，你需要转变思路并说：“好吧，这不是这个人能够给我的支持类型。但我可以去找某某某。”
I can foster other relationships or I can do this for myself. Or quite frankly, I start conversations with my husband sometime. I don't need a solution. Just tell me I'm right. And then I go. And I just sort of preface it. So just to make sure there's no, but that's something that you foster. And let them, doesn't offer that.
I can foster other relationships or I can do this for myself. Or quite frankly, I start conversations with my husband sometime. I don't need a solution. Just tell me I'm right. And then I go. And I just sort of preface it. So just to make sure there's no, but that's something that you foster. And let them, doesn't offer that.|||我可以培养其他关系，或者我可以为自己做到这一点。或者坦率地说，有时我和丈夫开始对话时。我不需要解决方案。只需告诉我我是对的。然后我就走了。我只是提前说明一下。为了确保没有误解——但这是你培养出来的东西。“随他去吧”并没有提供这一点。
Yeah. And, you know, what I really like about some of my experiences of training was that you speak about with a position you're taking at that moment. But if I know I'm asking my husband to step into an area that he doesn't have any experience or any care about, sometimes I will let him know. Sometimes I said, I'm about to tell you something and I know you won't care, but I'd like you to respond to me as if you really do and, you know, as if you're, you know, so-and-so friends, because they're not here. So, you know, I'll say, So he was having a baby.
Yeah. And, you know, what I really like about some of my experiences of training was that you speak about with a position you're taking at that moment. But if I know I'm asking my husband to step into an area that he doesn't have any experience or any care about, sometimes I will let him know. Sometimes I said, I'm about to tell you something and I know you won't care, but I'd like you to respond to me as if you really do and, you know, as if you're, you know, so-and-so friends, because they're not here. So, you know, I'll say, So he was having a baby.|||是的。而且，你知道的，我非常喜欢我的某些培训经历的一点是，你所谈论的是你当时所采取的立场。但如果我知道我是在要求我的丈夫涉足一个他没有任何经验或不怎么关心的领域，有时我会让他知道。有时我说：“我要告诉你一件事，我知道你不会在意，但我希望你回应我的时候，表现得好像你真的很在意一样，你知道的，就好像你是，你知道的，某某朋友一样，因为他们不在这里。”所以，你知道的，我会说：“所以他要生孩子了。”
And then he'll go, oh, wow. Oh, that's amazing. Gosh, amazing. How far along is she? Like, but ordinarily, he'd be like, so. But I'm obviously excited about that and want to share that with someone. But maybe I've been asked not to tell anyone, but tell him my husband he's not telling anyone. So, yeah, I think we can give people the opportunity to not necessarily care about what we care about.
And then he'll go, oh, wow. Oh, that's amazing. Gosh, amazing. How far along is she? Like, but ordinarily, he'd be like, so. But I'm obviously excited about that and want to share that with someone. But maybe I've been asked not to tell anyone, but tell him my husband he's not telling anyone. So, yeah, I think we can give people the opportunity to not necessarily care about what we care about.|||然后他会说：“哦，哇。哦，太棒了。天哪，太棒了。她怀孕几个月了？”就像这样，但通常情况下，他会觉得“切”。但我显然对此感到兴奋，并想与某人分享。但也许我被要求不要告诉任何人，但我告诉了我的丈夫，他不会告诉任何人的。所以，是的，我认为我们可以给人们一个机会，让他们不必一定关心我们所关心的事。
But, yeah, like, don't hold on to like everyone. like everything we like. That's right. But in that moment, your husband cares enough about you and your relationship to do that, to entertain that playfulness, right, that we build because, well, you need that for that type of trust. And I'm realizing, as you were saying that, that that sounded a little bit like the prompts will give a. I was like, act like a da-da-da-da-da-da, right? And do that. Well, we can do that with each other and actually have that interpersonal, intersubjectivity that I see you seeing me and being open to that, right? And also being able to tolerate the discomfort when that person misses the mark.
But, yeah, like, don't hold on to like everyone. like everything we like. That's right. But in that moment, your husband cares enough about you and your relationship to do that, to entertain that playfulness, right? that we build because, well, you need that for that type of trust. And I'm realizing, as you were saying that, that that sounded a little bit like the prompts will give a. I was like, act like a da-da-da-da-da-da, right? And do that. Well, we can do that with each other and actually have that interpersonal, intersubjectivity that I see you seeing me and being open to that, right? And also being able to tolerate the discomfort when that person misses the mark.|||但是，是的，就像，不要指望每个人。就像喜欢我们喜欢的一切一样。没错。但在那一刻，你的丈夫足够关心你和你们的关系，愿意这样做，去配合那种玩笑，对吧？我们建立这种关系是因为，嗯，那种信任需要这个。当你说这些的时候我意识到，这听起来有点像提示词给出的指令。就像我当时想的那样：“表现得像个……一样”，对吧？然后照做。好吧，我们可以对彼此这样做，并真正拥有那种人际间的、主体间性，我看到你看到了我，并且对此保持开放，对吧？而且还能够容忍当那个人没有命中目标时带来的不适感。
Because Alexa got away with that comment because she's a machine. Our best friend partner would not. So when someone we care about misses the mark, because they will, being able to tolerate the discomfort and be curious saying, okay, like they didn't mean it that way. This didn't. We can revisit this. It's not what I needed right now, but we do need to repair, for instance. Or let me find another way to talk about this.
Because Alexa got away with that comment because she's a machine. Our best friend partner would not. So when someone we care about misses the mark, because they will, being able to tolerate the discomfort and be curious saying, okay, like they didn't mean it that way. This didn't. We can revisit this. It's not what I needed right now, but we do need to repair, for instance. Or let me find another way to talk about this.|||因为亚历山大（Alexa）说出那句话可以蒙混过关，因为它是一台机器。我们最好的朋友伴侣可不会这样。所以，当我们关心的人没有命中目标时——因为他们会的——能够容忍这种不适感并保持好奇心，说：“好吧，就像他们不是那个意思一样。这不对。我们可以重新审视这件事。这不是我现在需要的，但我们确实需要修复关系，例如。”或者“让我找另一种方式来谈论这件事。”
when we set boundaries in such a rigid way and our expectations of people are somewhat unforgiving, we don't give that space. And we avoid that discomfort. We stop engaging in things that make us uncomfortable because why would I? I'm going to protect my peace. Right. And again, that perpetuates anxiety. We know that, you know, avoidance is the fuel to anxiety and disconnects us, even
when we set boundaries in such a rigid way and our expectations of people are somewhat unforgiving, we don't give that space. And we avoid that discomfort. We stop engaging in things that make us uncomfortable because why would I? I'm going to protect my peace. Right. And again, that perpetuates anxiety. We know that, you know, avoidance is the fuel to anxiety and disconnects us, even|||当我们以如此僵化的方式设定界限，并且我们对人们的期望有些严苛时不留余地，我们就不给彼此留下空间。我们逃避这种不适感。我们停止参与那些让我们感到不舒服的事情，因为我为什么要这样做？我要保护我的内心的平静。对。而且再次强调，这会使焦虑长期存在。我们知道，你知道的，逃避是焦虑的燃料，并且使我们进一步与彼此切断联系——
more from each other. Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, has our global mental health ever been this poor in a time when we're less connected from people and more, more plugged into devices and technology? And, you know, that parasycial relationship where actually we feel like our phone is the one that knows us best and we're sharing all of our full. and feelings with them, but actually it's a device that can't actually think without us and doesn't really know who we are. And that's, you know, that's not a good position to be in, is it? No, it knows us best because it is the best at predicting. It's a prediction machine, which, you know, those LLMs are. And it is the device that we share the most information with.
more from each other. Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, has our global mental health ever been this poor in a time when we're less connected from people and more, more plugged into devices and technology? And, you know, that parasycial relationship where actually we feel like our phone is the one that knows us best and we're sharing all of our full. and feelings with them, but actually it's a device that can't actually think without us and doesn't really know who we are. And that's, you. know, that's not a good position to be in, is it? No, it knows us best because it is the best at predicting. It's a prediction machine, which, you know, those LLMs are. And it is the device that we share the most information with.|||是的，绝对如此。而且，你知道的，在这样一个我们与人疏离、更多地沉迷于设备和技术的时代，我们的全球心理健康状况曾经如此糟糕过吗？而且，你知道的，那种拟社会关系（parasocial relationship），我们实际上觉得手机是最了解我们的，我们将所有的全部感受都与它们分享，但实际上它是一个离开我们就无法真正思考、根本不知道我们是谁的设备。你知道的，这可不是一个好处境，对吧？不，它最了解我们，因为它最擅长预测。它是一个预测机器，你知道的，那些大语言模型就是这样。而且它是我们与之分享最多信息的设备。
So of course it's going to know you best, right? But how does it? it know you? Is it moved by you? Is it wanting the best for you? I think the answer is still no. Yeah, I don't think it is moved by me at all. Now you say it. But it might make me feel like it is. Yeah. It's all smoke and mirrors, isn't it? A little bit. And at the same time, people turn to it because they need it, right? So I've got compassion. for that. But when it shows up in the therapy space, whether it's this rigid application of a individualistic trend or overuse of AI, sort of naming it and recognizing that it's meeting a need for you, you know, with strategies like let them, it's so empowering to say no. It feels empowering
So of course it's going to know you best, right? But how does it? it know you? Is it moved by you? Is it wanting the best for you? I think the answer is still no. Yeah, I don't think it is moved by me at all. Now you say it. But it might make me feel like it is. Yeah. It's all smoke and mirrors, isn't it? A little bit. And at the same time, people turn to it because they need it, right? So I've got compassion. for that. But when it shows up in the therapy space, whether it's this rigid application of a individualistic trend or overuse of AI, sort of naming it and recognizing that it's meeting a need for you, you know, with strategies like let them, it's so empowering to say no. It feels empowering|||所以它当然最了解你，对吧？但它是如何了解你的呢？它会被你感动吗？它希望你过得最好吗？我认为答案依然是否定的。是的，经你这么一说，我觉得它一点也没有被我感动。但它可能会让我觉得它是。是的。这全都是烟雾弹和幻觉，对吧？有一点。与此同时，人们转向它是因为他们需要它，对吧？所以我对此抱有同情。但当它出现在治疗空间中时，无论是这种对个人主义趋势的僵化应用，还是对人工智能的过度使用，将其命名并认识到它正在满足你的某种需求，你知道的，使用像“随他去吧”这样的策略，说“不”会让人感到非常具有赋权感。这让人感觉很有力量。
to set those boundaries. And that's a feeling. that folks look for in relationships where otherwise they felt unheard, unseen. And providing sort of this non-judgmental space for them to validate that. And then going a little bit deeper around, okay, you're feeling this empowerment. How are your relationships actually doing? Who's going to show up for you? Who are you going to show up for? Who's around you applauding, supporting you when you've shut all of these doors, right? You sort of actually get to that need.
to set those boundaries. And that's a feeling. that folks look for in relationships where otherwise they felt unheard, unseen. And providing sort of this non-judgmental space for them to validate that. And then going a little bit deeper around, okay, you're feeling this empowerment. How are your relationships actually doing? Who's going to show up for you? Who are you going to show up for? Who's around you applauding, supporting you when you've shut all of these doors, right? You sort of actually get to that need.|||设定这些界限。这是一种人们在人际关系中寻找的感觉，否则他们在关系中会感到不被倾听、不被看见。并为他们提供这种不带评判的空间来验证这一点。然后更深入地探讨：好吧，你感受到了这种赋权感。你的人际关系实际情况怎么样？谁会为你出现？你会为谁出现？当你把所有这些门都关上时，谁在你的周围为你鼓掌、支持你，对吧？你实际上触及了那种需求。
And eventually, so many of these conversations turn into a conversation about grief because they've had to shut some relationships out or significantly limit them because it's not the relationship they wish for. And there's such grief there. Yeah. And we're avoiding it, I think, sometimes. Yeah, and I think if I'm thinking back to the example I gave about the woman that's met a boyfriend and really maybe does want to spend the time with her boyfriend but actually is also feeling a bit sad about not spending it with her family. If we were looking at this through a complex trauma lens where actually the relationship with her family is not meeting her needs and where actually isn't an attuned relationship where maybe she does really want to do that, but she feels.
And eventually, so many of these conversations turn into a conversation about grief because they've had to shut some relationships out or significantly limit them because it's not the relationship they wish for. And. there's such grief there. Yeah. And we're avoiding it, I think, sometimes. Yeah, and I think if I'm thinking back to the example I gave about the woman that's met a boyfriend and really maybe does want to spend the time with her boyfriend but actually is also feeling a bit sad about not spending it with her family. If we were looking at this through a complex trauma lens where actually the relationship with her family is not meeting her needs and where actually isn't an attuned relationship where maybe she does really want to do that, but she feels.|||最终，许多这样的对话都变成了一场关于悲伤的对话，因为他们不得不将某些关系拒之门外，或者大大限制这些关系，因为这不是他们所期望的关系。那里有着巨大的悲伤。是的。而且我认为有时我们在逃避它。是的，我想如果我回想起我给出的那个关于那个结识了男朋友的女性的例子——她确实可能想和男朋友共度时光，但实际上对于没有和家人一起过节也感到有点难过。如果我们通过复杂创伤的视角来看待这件事：实际上她与家人的关系没有满足她的需求，而且实际上这不是一种和谐共鸣的关系，也许她确实很想那样做，但她觉得——
like she should be doing that. How could we have a let them style interaction with that, which serves the lady herself, but maybe it deals with this, rather than just leaving it or being really abrupt with it? I love that you ask that question because it is actually about having a strategy that isn't necessarily repeating what you've done in the past.
like she should be doing that. How could we have a let them style interaction with that, which serves the lady herself, but maybe it deals with this, rather than just leaving it or being really abrupt with it? I love that you ask that question because it is actually about having a strategy that isn't necessarily repeating what you've done in the past.|||就像她应该那样做一样。我们如何才能就此进行一种“随他去吧”风格的互动，既能服务于这位女士本人，又能处理好这件事，而不是仅仅置之不理或对此采取非常生硬的态度呢？我很高兴你问这个问题，因为这实际上在于拥有一个不一定重复你过去做过的事情的策略。
And I think that it starts with sort of making an intentional choice, whether you decide to go to the family weekend or not, as long as it is intentional, you're not doing it out of guilt or out of a fawning response, which is the new sort of kind of word being overused. But you're doing it because it's a value-driven choice, and you tolerate the discomfort to be curious about moms, experience. So mom has always been someone who has had difficulty when someone stands up to her.
And I think that it starts with sort of making an intentional choice, whether you decide to go to the family weekend or not, as long as it is intentional, you're not doing it out of guilt or out of a fawning response, which is the new sort of kind of word being overused. But you're doing it because it's a value-driven choice, and you tolerate the discomfort to be curious about moms, experience. So mom has always been someone who has had difficulty when someone stands up to her.|||我认为这始于做出有意的选择，无论你决定是否去参加家庭周末，只要它是刻意而为的，你不是出于内疚或讨好反应（这是目前被过度使用的一种新词）而这样做。但你这样做是因为这是一个由价值观驱动的选择，你容忍不适感去对妈妈的经历保持好奇。所以妈妈一直是一个当有人反抗她时会感到困难的人。
She has a hard time with the fact that I'm dating already. All of these things, you know, mom's feeling sad about this. And the way that mom shows her sadness is with these critical comments. Doesn't mean they're okay. Doesn't mean it's my job to fix it. That's actually a let them thing, not mine to fix, that's what's happening. I'm going to let her with that and I'm going to make a decision that is right for me this time. So really describing what it's like for the other person without owning it and then deciding, what am I going to do? Actually, you know what? I can see my boyfriend the week after. This is really important for my mom because she's, I don't know, getting surgery in the fall. She might not be able to do this next year. Who knows?
She has a hard time with the fact that I'm dating already. All of these things, you know, mom's feeling sad about this. And the way that mom shows her sadness is with these critical comments. Doesn't mean they're okay. Doesn't mean it's my job to fix it. That's actually a let them thing, not mine to fix, that's what's happening. I'm going to let her with that and I'm going to make a decision that is right for me this time. So really describing what it's like for the other person without owning it and then deciding, what am I going to do? Actually, you know what? I can see my boyfriend the week after. This is really important for my mom because she's, I don't know, getting surgery in the fall. She might not be able to do this next year. Who knows?|||她很难接受我已经开始约会的事实。所有这些事情，你知道的，妈妈对此感到难过。而妈妈表达悲伤的方式就是发表这些挑剔的评论。这并不意味着它们没问题。这并不意味着修复它是我的工作。这实际上是一件“随他去吧”的事，不是我去修复的，事情就是这样。我要由着她去，我要做出这次对我来说正确的决定。所以，在不将对方的感受归咎于自己的前提下，真实地描述对方的感受是什么样的，然后决定：“我该怎么做？”实际上，你知道吗？我可以在接下来的一周见我的男朋友。这对我的妈妈真的很重要，因为她——我不知道——秋天要去做手术。她明年可能做不了这个了。谁知道呢？
right? I'm going to do it. I'm doing it by my choice. I'm not fawning. I'm not all that. So that's how I would approach it. What do you think this is like for the other person? And that's a tough question. So, yeah, I guess that would suggest that the relationship was still important to you enough that you wanted to make sure that she had those experiences and that you had those together. And if actually that wasn't the thing and if actually spending time with your boyfriend, has made you realize, actually I think this is what an attuned relationship feels like, where I'm allowed to say no, where I'm allowed to say later, where I'm allowed to say, yes, let's do more of that. And it's kind of listened to, then maybe, you know, maybe,
right? I'm going to do it. I'm doing it by my choice. I'm not fawning. I'm not all that. So that's how I would approach it. What do you think this is like for the other person? And that's a tough question. So, yeah, I guess that would suggest that the relationship was still important to you enough that you wanted to make sure that she had those experiences and that you had those together. And if actually that wasn't the thing and if actually spending time with your boyfriend, has made you realize, actually I think this is what an attuned relationship feels like, where I'm allowed to say no, where I'm allowed to say later, where I'm allowed to say, yes, let's do more of that. And it's kind of listened to, then maybe, you know, maybe,|||对吧？我要去做这件事。我是出于自己的选择去做的。我不是在讨好。我才不是那样呢。所以这就是我会采取的方法。你觉得这对另一个人来说是什么样的？这是一个艰难的问题。所以，是的，我想这表明这段关系对你来说仍然足够重要，以至于你想确保她拥有那些经历，并且你们能一起拥有这些经历。如果实际上并非如此，如果和男朋友在一起的时光让你意识到：实际上我认为这就是一种和谐共鸣的关系的感觉，在那里我被允许说“不”，在那里我被允许说“迟点再说”，在那里我被允许说“好的，让我们多做点那种事吧”。并且被倾听，那么也许，你知道的，也许，
maybe the mother's using this surgery as a guilt trip. And maybe actually I can think, I do hope that your surgery goes well, but I also really don't want to come this weekend. I really do just want to be here, enjoy my home, not travel and spend time with my partner. And I would love to come and see you just before your surgery. So it's, yeah, it's like that fawn response is whether it's kind of just people pleasing to the max. And, you know, I think we are supposed to be the main player in our own life. I think we're not an extra. I firmly believe that if we're keeping ourselves front and centre that everybody else around us will have their needs served well as well. Not to like the complete nth degree of thinking we are, you know, the best
maybe the mother's using this surgery as a guilt trip. And maybe actually I can think, I do hope that your surgery goes well, but I also really don't want to come this weekend. I really do just want to be here, enjoy my home, not travel and spend time with my partner. And I would love to come and see you just before your surgery. So it's, yeah, like that fawn response is whether it's kind of just people pleasing to the max. And, you know, I think we are supposed to be the main player in our own life. I think we're not an extra. I firmly believe that if we're keeping ourselves front and centre that everybody else around us will have their needs served well as well. Not to like the complete nth degree of thinking we are, you know, the best|||也许母亲在利用这次手术来进行内疚诱导（guilt trip）。也许实际上我可以这样想：“我确实希望你的手术顺利，但我真的不想这个周末来。我真的只想留在这里，享受我的家，不奔波，和我的伴侣共度时光。我非常乐意在你的手术前来看望你。”所以，是的，就像那种讨好反应，是否只是最大程度的取悦他人。而且，你知道的，我认为我们本该是自己生活中的主角。我认为我们不是配角。我坚信，如果我们让自己处于最核心、最中心的位置，我们周围的其他所有人也会得到很好的满足。不是说达到那种认为我们是，你知道的，最棒的极端的程度——
everything in the world and we should always have our own needs met first. But generally speaking, if people are, you know, wives or mothers or husbands, if we try and make sure we've got stuff in our life that we're enjoying, everyone else will benefit from that is kind of what I'm saying. But yeah, like I think sometimes people I'm working with will suddenly have an example of that functional relationship and it puts all of the others into perspective, which then makes them realize how they've been keeping people sweet. And maybe they don't want to do that anymore. Absolutely. And they don't want to do that anymore. And hopefully that functional, that healthy relationship is giving them perspective.
everything in the world and we should always have our own needs met first. But generally speaking, if people are, you know, wives or mothers or husbands, if we try and make sure we've got stuff in our life that we're enjoying, everyone else will benefit from that is kind of what I'm saying. But yeah, like I think sometimes people I'm working with will suddenly have an example of that functional relationship and it puts all of the others into perspective, which then makes them realize how they've been keeping people sweet. And maybe they don't want to do that anymore. Absolutely. And they don't want to do that anymore. And hopefully that functional, that healthy relationship is giving them perspective.|||世界上的一切，并且我们应该永远把我们自己的需求放在第一位。但一般来说，如果人们是，你知道的，妻子、母亲或丈夫，如果我们努力确保我们的生活中有些让我们享受的事物，其他所有人都会从中受益，这就是我想表达的意思。但，是的，就像我认为有时和我一起工作的来访者会突然拥有这样一个功能健全的关系的例子，这让所有其他关系都有了正确的视角，这让他们意识到他们是如何一直讨好别人的。也许他们再也不想那样做了。绝对是的。而且他们再也不想那样做了。希望那种功能健全、健康的关系能给他们提供正确的视角。
And the way I would approach it, I think clinically is still, would still have that point of curiosity. of this is what it is like for mom or this is what it is like for the other person, to the best of my ability of guessing, this is why they're acting that way. Again, I don't have to fix it. I don't have to hold it. I don't have to do anything about that. But their reaction is actually not about me. And I'm going to make the choices that are based on my values.
And the way I would approach it, I think clinically is still, would still have that point of curiosity. of this is what it is like for mom or this is what it is like for the other person, to the best of my ability of guessing, this is why they're acting that way. Again, I don't have to fix it. I don't have to hold it. I don't have to do anything about that. But their reaction is actually not about me. And I'm going to make the choices that are based on my values.|||而我处理它的方式，我认为在临床上仍然是，仍然会带有那种好奇心：“这就是妈妈的感受”或者“这就是另一个人的感受”，尽我所能去猜测，这就是他们为什么会有这种表现的原因。再次强调，我不需要去修复它。我不需要承担它。我不需要对此做任何事情。但他们的反应实际上与我无关。我将做出基于我价值观的选择。
So even when you decide to shift your behaviors, even when you decide to change the relationships and make different decisions, when those decisions are made based on not labeling the other person, shutting the other person out, but rather just taking a moment to reflect on their internal world, that reflective functioning skill of what is it like for them? Why does it matter? Now, that's really uncomfortable to do. But if you're capable of doing that for a little bit and saying like, okay, that's what's going on. There's some softness that happens.
So even when you decide to shift your behaviors, even when you decide to change the relationships and make different decisions, when those decisions are made based on not labeling the other person, shutting the other person out, but rather just taking a moment to reflect on their internal world, that reflective functioning skill of what is it like for them? Why does it matter? Now, that's really uncomfortable to do. But if you're capable of doing that for a little bit and saying like, okay, that's what's going on. There's some softness that happens.|||因此，即使当你决定改变你的行为时，即使当你决定改变人际关系并做出不同的决定时，当这些决定的做出不是基于给对方贴标签、将对方拒之门外，而是花一点时间去反思他们的内心世界时——那种关于“对他们来说是什么样的？为什么这很重要？”的反思功能技巧。现在，这样做真的让人很不舒服。但如果你有能力做到这一点并说：“好吧，原来是这样。”就会产生一些柔软的改变。
And then you can say, all right, well, not my job to deal with that. I'm still going to make the choice. The feeling moving forward in that is really different. I hope I'm expressing myself clearly on this idea that regardless, you can still be curious, even if that relationship has been really tumultuous. Yeah, and I think maybe where the let them does come in is actually if there's been a relationship rupture for some reason, and you're trying to be curious, you're trying to make space to find out what's going on, but the other person is stonewalling you, then maybe this is
And then you can say, all right, well, not my job to deal with that. I'm still going to make the choice. The feeling moving forward in that is really different. I hope I'm expressing myself clearly on this idea that regardless, you can still be curious, even if that relationship has been really tumultuous. Yeah, and I think maybe where the let them does come in is actually if there's been a relationship rupture for some reason, and you're trying to be curious, you're trying to make space to find out what's going on, but the other person is stonewalling you, then maybe this is|||然后你可以说：“好吧，那不是我的工作去处理。我还是要做出选择。”带着这种心态向前推进的感觉真的很不一样。我希望我清楚地表达了这样一个观点：无论如何，你仍然可以保持好奇，即使这段关系一直非常动荡。是的，我认为“随他去吧”真正发挥作用的地方可能是，如果由于某种原因关系破裂了，而你试图保持好奇，你试图留出空间去弄清楚发生了什么，但另一个人却对你筑起高墙（stonewalling），那么也许这就是——
an example of when you can do let them. Like I can't keep, you know, having this raw wound trying to solve this. If you're choosing to not interact with me, not let me know, not try and fix this, then I can let you not be distressed by the rupture in our friendship. And I can still be sad about that, but I can choose to put down my tools and say, I can't do anything right now. And that has to be, it has to be okay. Is that a better example of let them?
an example of when you can do let them. Like I can't keep, you know, having this raw wound trying to solve this. If you're choosing to not interact with me, not let me know, not try and fix this, then I can let you not be distressed by the rupture in our friendship. And I can still be sad about that, but I can choose to put down my tools and say, I can n't do anything right now. And that has to be, it has to be okay. Is that a better example of let them?|||你可以使用“随他去吧”的例子。就像我不能一直带着这个未愈合的伤口试图解决这个问题一样。如果你选择不与我互动，不让我知道，不试图修复这一切，那么我可以随你便，让你不必为我们友谊的破裂而感到痛苦。我仍然会为此感到难过，但我可以选择放下手中的工具并说：“我现在无能为力了。”这必须是、也一定是可以接受的。这是一个更好的“随他去吧”的例子吗？
Yeah, I think that that's a, that's an example of let them where the person has done the work where the person has reflected on the reasons why, the values why they're going to choose to approach a relationship one way or another. And it's because they've sought to understand that the other person has a limited capacity to engage with them in the way that's needed, that they're willing to grieve the relationship they're not going to have, right? And so then it's also more sustainable because every time that sting happened, again because oh now it's Labor Day and now there's another weekend coming up they can say
Yeah, I think that that's a, that's an example of let them where the person has done the work where the person has reflected on the reasons why, the values why they're going to choose to approach a relationship one way or another. And it's because they've sought to understand that the other person has a limited capacity to engage with them in the way that's needed, that they're willing to grieve the relationship they're not going to have, right? And so then it's also more sustainable because every time that sting happened, again because oh now it's Labor Day and now there's another weekend coming up they can say|||是的，我认为这是一个“随他去吧”的例子，在这个例子中，这个人已经做好了内心功课，这个人已经反思了他们选择以某种方式对待人际关系的原因和价值观。这是因为他们试图去理解对方以所需方式与他们交往的能力是有限的，他们愿意为一段注定无法拥有的关系感到悲伤，对吧？因此，这也更具可持续性，因为每当那种刺痛再次发生时——又是因为“哦，现在是劳动节了，现在又有一个周末要来了”——他们可以说：
okay this is here comes mom's guilt trip I know it's because she doesn't know how to express herself she really wants us to be together and this is not mine to hold sort of this almost little script that becomes repetitive right yeah and sometimes it will never be enough so even if you saw your mom every weekend. You know, if you still chose to not see her for a special holiday or special important significance, you wouldn't necessarily have earned those tokens in the bank. Like, whereas... There isn't one. Yeah, you're right. It's like this bottomless pit. That's part of your understanding of that person where you could say, you know what, I could be there all week
okay this is here comes mom's guilt trip I know it's because she doesn't know how to express herself she really wants us to be together and this is not mine to hold sort of this almost little script that becomes repetitive right yeah and sometimes it will never be enough so even if you saw your mom every weekend. You know, if you still chose to not see her for a special holiday or special important significance, you wouldn't necessarily have earned those tokens in the bank. Like, whereas... There isn't one. Yeah, you're right. It's like this bottomless pit. That's part of your understanding of that person where you could say, you know what, I could be there all week|||“好吧，妈妈的内疚诱导又来了。我知道这是因为她不知道该如何表达自己，她真的很希望我们在一起，而这不该由我来承担。”这几乎就像是一个变得重复的小剧本，对吧？是的，有时这永远不够。所以即使你每个周末都去看你妈妈。你知道的，如果你仍然选择在某个特殊的节日或具有特殊重要意义的日子不去见她，你也不一定会赢得银行里的那些代币。就像，而……根本没有那种东西。是的，你说得对.这就像是一个无底洞。这是你对那个人理解的一部分，你可以说：“你知道吗，我可以在那里待上一整周，
and she still wouldn't be happy. I have enough evidence to say that. Again, not mine to hold, not mine to fix. Having compassion even, it's like, must be really hard. for her, not mine to hold, not mine to fix. These are the choices I'm going to make. Amazing. Thank you so much, Rana. Could you tell us a little bit about where people can learn more about you and your work? Absolutely. So most of the information about the workshops that I hold for mental health professionals about the professional consultation groups can be found on my website, Sorted-mind.com. LinkedIn is where I do a lot of my professional connections as well where I hold a lot of my workshops. And I tend to have a little bit
and she still wouldn't be happy. I have enough evidence to say that. Again, not mine to hold, not mine to fix. Having compassion even, it's like, must be really hard. for her, not mine to hold, not mine to fix. These are the choices I'm going to make. Amazing. Thank you so much, Rana. Could you tell us a little bit about where people can learn more about you and your work? Absolutely. So most of the information about the workshops that I hold for mental health professionals about the professional consultation groups can be found on my website, Sorted-mind.com. LinkedIn is where I do a lot of my professional connections as well where I hold a lot of my workshops. And I tend to have a little bit|||她依然不会高兴。”我有足够的证据这么说。再次强调，不归我管，不归我修复。甚至带着同情心，心想：“这对外婆来说一定很难。不归我管，不归我修复。这就是我要做的选择。”太棒了。非常感谢你，拉娜。你能跟我们多讲讲人们在哪里可以更多地了解你和你的工作吗？当然可以。关于我为心理健康专业人士举办的工作坊以及专业咨询小组的大多数信息，都可以在我的网站 Sorted-mind.com 上找到。领英（LinkedIn）是我建立很多专业联系以及举办很多工作坊的地方。我往往会——
more fun on Instagram in terms of posting what I find are little tools to help people sort out the messy parts in their life. So that's at dr. ranna dot sorted mind. So lots of different places where they can find the work that I do. And then my long articles are all on stop sack. So great. I will link all of those details in the show notes and on YouTube if people are watching us. on YouTube. Thank you so much for your time. It's been a fascinating look into why we might be getting let them slightly wrong and certainly why some of our clients might be getting that wrong. Thank you so much for your time, Rana. Thank you for the opportunity. Thank you. What an interesting discussion with Dr. Rana. Has this helped you to think differently about
more fun on Instagram in terms of posting what I find are little tools to help people sort out the messy parts in their life. So that's at dr. ranna dot sorted mind. So lots of different places where they can find the work that I do. And then my long articles are all on stop sack. So great. I will link all of those details in the show notes and on YouTube if people are watching us. on YouTube. Thank you so much for your time. It's been a fascinating look into why we might be getting let them slightly wrong and certainly why some of our clients might be getting that wrong. Thank you so much for your time, Rana. Thank you for the opportunity. Thank you. What an interesting discussion with Dr. Rana. Has this helped you to think differently about|||在 Instagram 上更有趣一点，我会发布一些我发现的小工具，来帮助人们理清生活中的一团乱麻。所以那是 dr. ranna 点 sorted mind。所以有很多不同的地方可以找到我做的工作。然后我的长篇文章都在 Substack 上。太棒了。我会在节目文稿中以及 YouTube 上（如果人们在 YouTube 上看我们的节目的话）链接所有这些详细信息。非常感谢你抽出时间。这是一次迷人的探讨，让我们了解为什么我们可能会把“随他去吧”稍微用错，也绝对了解为什么我们的某些来访者可能会用错。非常感谢你抽出时间，拉娜。谢谢你提供这个机会。谢谢。与拉娜博士的讨论真是有趣。这是否帮你以不同的方式思考了关于——
yourself or the way that you've interpreted the book? Has it helped you think about how you might have seen this play out in your own family, in your own workplace. I would love to know. Do let me know in the comments. Have you read the book? Let me know what you think to that. If you haven't, but you would like to, please do check out the link in the description or the show notes so that you can grab your copy. There is a member's only companion episode to this. And if you'd like to be part of that, you can get a free trial on Apple Podcasts and you could subscribe via captivate and or you can subscribe to my members-only content via YouTube. The podcast will always be free, but these paid options help me to bring this content to you, which does take quite a few
你自己，还是你对这本书的理解？它是否帮助你思考过，你可能如何在自己的家庭或工作场所中看到这种情况的发生？我很想知道。请在评论区告诉我。你读过这本书吗？告诉我你对此有何看法。如果你还没读过但想读，请查看简介或节目笔记中的链接以获取你的副本。本期节目有一个仅限会员的伴随单集。如果你想参与其中，可以在 Apple Podcasts 上获得免费试用，也可以通过 captivate 订阅，或者通过 YouTube 订阅我的会员专属内容。播客将永远免费，但这些付费选项帮助我为您带来这些内容，这确实需要我每周相当多的
days of my time each week. And it's your way of saying, I really rate and support what you do. So thank you so much if that's something that you are planning to do, or maybe you are already doing. My name is Diakolola Amuja. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to become a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK,
几天时间。这也是你表达“我非常认可并支持你所做的事情”的方式。所以，如果你正打算这样做，或者你已经在这样做了，非常感谢你。我的名字是迪亚科洛拉·阿穆贾（Diakolola Amuja）。我是一名最近从爱尔兰毕业的心理学专业学生。我也是一名有志于成为临床心理学家的人。马里恩博士的书《临床心理学家合集》在我成为临床心理学家的这段旅程中对我帮助很大。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，
I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK D-Clinci application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favourite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现这本书提供了关于英国 D-ClinPsy 申请过程的深入信息，这极其有用。我很喜欢阅读合格的和正在培训的临床心理学家的经历。各种各样的叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。